♪♪
Narrator:
NO ONE KNOWS WHO CAME UP WITH
THE IDEA OF SQUEEZING ORANGES
TO MAKE JUICE.
THE POPULARITY OF ORANGE JUICE
INCREASED DRAMATICALLY
IN THE MIDDLE
OF THE 20th CENTURY
AS TECHNIQUES WERE DEVELOPED
TO EXTEND ITS SHELF LIFE.
TODAY, MANY PEOPLE START THEIR
DAY WITH A TALL GLASS OF OJ.
IN ITS PUREST FORM,
ORANGE JUICE IS FRESH-SQUEEZED
AND MADE WITH NO PRESERVATIVES
OR OTHER ADDITIVES.
THE APPEAL IS INDISPUTABLE.
FRESH-SQUEEZED OJ
CONTAINS VITAMIN C,
AND THE FLAVOR IS AUTHENTIC.
ORANGE JUICE PRODUCTION
STARTS IN GROVES.
THE TREES TAKE SEVERAL MONTHS
TO BEAR FRUIT,
AND ARE HARVESTED
IN EARLY NOVEMBER.
♪♪
PICKING ORANGES IS A JOB
THAT'S DONE ENTIRELY BY HAND.
AN AUTOMATED PICKING SYSTEM
COULD DAMAGE
BOTH THE TREES AND THE FRUIT.
THE PICKER USES A BAG MADE
OF VINYL COMPOSITE
THAT'S LIGHTWEIGHT
AND HEAVY-DUTY.
THERE ARE MULTIPLE TYPES OF
JUICING ORANGES.
THIS ONE IS CALLED THE HAMLIN.
HAMLIN ORANGES
ARE SMALL AND JUICY,
THE TREES THEY GROW ON
ARE PRODUCTIVE
AND RESILIENT TO COLD.
THE PICKER PLUCKS THE FRUIT
FROM THE TREES
BEFORE THEY TURN ORANGE.
THEY MAY BE GREEN
ON THE OUTSIDE,
BUT THEY ARE STILL SWEET
ON THE INSIDE.
THE FRUITS'
SIZE AND CONDITION
ARE INDICATIONS
OF MATURITY AND FLAVOR.
AS THE PICKER EMPTIES THE BAG
INTO A BIN,
HE EXAMINES THE ORANGES.
ANYTHING WITH TEARS OR PUNCTURES
MAY ALSO HAVE
INTERNAL DEGRADATION,
BUT SUPERFICIAL FLAWS WON'T
AFFECT THE QUALITY OF THE JUICE.
THE ORANGES ARE TAKEN TO A
PROCESSING FACILITY,
AND TRANSFERRED
TO A SLOPED CHUTE.
♪♪
THE GRADIENT OF THE CHUTE
PREVENTS DAMAGE,
AS THE ORANGES TUMBLE
INTO A WASH STATION.
♪♪
A SPRAYER RAINS SOAPY WATER
ONTO THE ORANGES
AS SPIRALING NYLON
BRUSHES SCRUB AND CLEAN
WHILE SIMULTANEOUSLY
MOVING THEM FORWARD.
♪♪
AFTER THE WASH,
ANOTHER SPRAYER RINSES THEM OFF
AS THE SPIRALING BRUSHES
CONTINUE SCRUBBING.
THE ORANGES TRANSITION
TO A ROLLER CONVEYOR
THAT TAKES THEM
UP AND UNDER FANS.
♪♪
AS THE ORANGES EXIT THE DRYER,
AN INSPECTOR CHECKS THEM
FOR ANY MISSED DAMAGE.
♪♪
THE ORANGES TRAVEL ACROSS
MORE REVOLVING BRUSHES.
THE BRISTLES ON THESE BRUSHES
ARE GENTLER
THAN ON THE FIRST GROUP.
THEY BUFF THE SKIN OF THE FRUIT
AND REMOVE ANY RESIDUAL DIRT.
♪♪
FINALLY, THE ORANGES
FALL OFF THE CONVEYOR LINE
INTO A BIN.
NOW CLEANED,
THE ORANGES CAN BE JUICED
WITH NO CONTAMINANTS THAT COULD
SPOIL EITHER THE PRODUCT
OR JUICING MACHINERY.
AS A FINAL PRECAUTION,
THE JUICING OPERATOR
PERFORMS ONE LAST INSPECTION.
IF SHE'S COMPLETELY SATISFIED
WITH THEIR CLEANLINESS
AND GENERAL CONDITION,
SHE LOADS THE ORANGES
INTO THE EXTRACTOR.
♪♪
THERE'S NO NEED TO SLICE THEM
BEFOREHAND.
SHE FEEDS THEM TO
THE JUICING MACHINE WHOLE.
THE SYSTEM FEEDS THE ORANGES
ONE AT A TIME TO THE EXTRACTOR.
THE EXTRACTOR
PUNCTURES THE FRUIT,
AND METAL TEETH PEEL
AWAY THE SKIN.
IT SQUEEZES OUT THE JUICE
WHILE SIMULTANEOUSLY
FILTERING OUT THE SEEDS,
AND THE MEMBRANE BETWEEN
THE FLESH OF THE ORANGE
AND THE SKIN.
THE JUICE FLOWS INTO A VAT.
A SCREEN IN THE VAT
FILTERS THE PULP TO
THE DESIRED CONSISTENCY --
THERE ARE SEVERAL
DIFFERENT FILTERS
FOR DIFFERENT AMOUNTS
OF PULP.
THE JUICE IS BOTTLED IN JUGS.
THE PLASTIC JUGS WILL
ACCOMMODATE ANY EXPANSION
OF THE UNPASTEURIZED JUICE
DUE TO FERMENTATION.
INSTEAD OF PASTEURIZING THIS
FRESH-SQUEEZED JUICE,
IT IS CHILLED IMMEDIATELY.
THE UNPASTEURIZED ORANGE JUICE
WON'T HAVE
AN EXTENDED SHELF LIFE,
BUT THE TRADE-OFF IS
AN UNALTERED FLAVOR AND COLOR.
♪♪
REFRIGERATION WILL PRESERVE
THE JUICE FOR A FEW DAYS,
AND AFTER ALL,
FRESH-SQUEEZED ORANGE JUICE
IS A DRINK
THAT'S BEST SERVED COLD.